CBS
DBS which is mostly crap at least their
news Division I don't know what's going
on on the entertainment Division I don't
have cable anymore uh they aired a
segment about the parental rights
movement that is proliferating
throughout the country uh they talked to
my friends over at Mom's for Liberty
podcast and it wasn't terrible and I
thought okay that's sort of interesting
here's just a little bit
the book genderqueer was in our school
libraries had mom's for Liberty not
brought that book to your attention it
might still be there launched in 2021
the group now claims
275 chapters in 45 states with 115
000 members and Counting never bet
against a mom I mean nobody's going to
defend anything like a mom is going to
defend their child
Tiffany Justice and Tina daskovich both
former Florida school board members
founded moms for liberty for joyful
words joyful Warrior their aim to play
hardball with a smile we are organized
we are angry and we know our rights
enjoy the time you have left we want
people who are serving an elected office
that respect the role of the parent in a
child's life so in 2022 our chapters
endorse in over 500 School Board races
across the country and they won 275
seats what kinds of books do you want in
schools in libraries books that educate
children
that's a generalization that the books
that don't have pornography in them
let's start there let's just put the bar
really really low books that don't have
incest pedophilia you see what I'm
showing you guys here CBS which has been
unkind to say the least and NBC and ABC
and all of them which have been really
unkind to parental rights and education
the bills the politicians that are
pushing it Forward they lie about don't
say gay and what what's happening with
the books and all of those things even
now they're like oh I guess we can't
totally hide this so they did like us I
don't know basically a fairly decent
piece
for people on our side and that is good
but it's only good well no it's good for
many reasons but it's only possible
because more and more people are
stepping up and fighting for the right
thing I've met those ladies they're
they're fine ladies actually the moms of
Liberty I've done a couple things with
them and some Florida blueprint events
and hopefully I'll do some things in the
future and I've done their podcast and
and a bunch more but the point here guys
is that something positive comes when
you tell the truth
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]